c'est non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
bavarois
la nostalgie c'est comme les coups de
soleil ça fait pas mal pendant ça fait
mal le soir
j'ai attrapé un gros coup de nostalgie
vespérale après m'être promené l'autre
jour dans la rue saint-marc derrière les
grands boulevards
c'est une petite rue perpendiculaire à
la rue de richelieu tout près d'un
immeuble m'as-tu-vu où siégeaient
naguère un journal du matin qui avait un
nom de l'aube et où j'ai appris à
raconter des choses en baratte en démo
sur du papier
le journal du matin a été phagocyté
depuis par un célèbre épurateurs
d'opinion
il reste la façade et les murs derrière
lesquels s'agite désormais des assureurs
lustré et des [ __ ] de banque et rien
plus rien de la volaille de plumes et de
flash qui menait grand bruissement et
picaresque éclat et qui s'est égayée
depuis au hasard des excroissances de
médias polis
l'imprimerie du journal s'ouvrait par un
grand porche noir qui repoussait dans
cette rue saint-marc ses effluves chargé
de l'air lourd des machines et de la
sueur des hommes qui sentent l ancrer le
papier show à la tombée de chacune des
trois éditions de la nuit c'était la
ruée des journalistes et des ouvriers du
marbre sur les trois bistrots qui ne
fermaient jamais car les gens de presse
d'alors faisait les trois 8,8 au lit
huit auteurs et 8 à boire
oui les journalistes boivent beaucoup
c'est une c'est une constante de leur
métier qu'ils partagent avec les
chômeurs et les militaires qui eux aussi
distille le plus clair de leur temps à
rentrer les épaules dans l'attenté
angoissée de ce qui va leur tomber sur
la gueule
un triste jour et pour de bon la rue
saint marc a bouclé la dernière édition
de ses éclats de nuit alors comme le pic
boeuf s'enfuit du cuir du buffle morts
l'auvergnate bistrot sentant venir la
fin prochaine du quartier comateux repli
son grand tablier bleu il met son
tonneau de bordeaux supérieur sur son
dos et s'envole en pleurant sur les
copains d'ivresse vers des lendemains
plus clinquant dans des snacks burke
américain nous l'en n'est pas tenue pour
qu'on vous servent à boire de dire
bonjour en s'offusquant du retour des
frimas
par miracle merci mon dieu vous méritez
la une
l'un des trois troquet de la rue saint
marc a survécu celui où nous traînions
le moins parce qu'il était à 20 mètres
près le plus loin des 3 je veux dire le
plus reculé par rapport à cette
improbable mais très précises frontières
qui marque aussi bien le territoire du
loup que le bout de quartier des hommes
comme l'autre en sa galère calèche faire
dans cet antre en fumée tout agitée de
travailleurs éclectique et de matamore
de la fripe échappé du sentier
je n'avais même pas soif je revenais de
quelques rendez-vous à ferrer et ce
n'était même pas mon chemin pour aller
aux taxis
jeremy hills ou si grandiose en tête qui
n'abritait de légumes des jours anciens
et des souvenirs des copains enquête et
filatures en tout genre pourquoi at il
fallu comme un vieux compte cheval qui
retourne au picotin que je pousse à cela
porte à battant pour aller réclamer un
demi et me poser sur un tabouret de bar
auprès d'un vieux cassé sur un ballon
d'alsace
c'était un ancien photographe pigiste
qui n'avait pas eu la force d'émigrés
avec le gros du troupeau parce qu'il
était déjà trop usés au moment de la
fermeture du journal au fur et à mesure
qu'on avait démoli les deux autres
bistrots pour en faire une boutique
putassière deir balaa zaraï et un
atelier de tissage pour baba cool
exténué on l'avait repoussé dehors en
même temps que les gravats jusqu'à ce
qu'il tombe du caniveau dans la débauche
obscur des petits naufrage éthylique
il m'a gratifié d'un hochement de tête
amical appuyé d'un sourire fatigué mais
entendu qu'ils voulaient dire qu'il
n'avait pas oublié toutes ces choses de
nos petites vies frétillante de ce temps
là
et puis il s'est péniblement repoussé du
bar en s'appuyant dès demain et il a
tapoté gentiment l'étui du relais flex
qui lui pendait tout coup en mono
rendent un coup d'oeil complices
ensuite il a dit rooney tu ne remet ça
et j'ai dit non non c'est moi comme
l'exigent le protocole et il a dit et
alors qu'est ce que tu deviens
et j'ai dit que je devenais tour à tour
papa presbytes est plutôt bien dans mes
chaussures
et toi toujours dans la photo
il a exhalé un soupir bizarre comme un
sanglot pas fini il a posé son verre il
a brandi le relais vers moi d'une main
et appuyé de l'autre sur le poussoir de
l'étui
il était vide
le soir même il y avait une petite fête
à la maison où l'on arrive bon goût en
avançant des idées positives au dessus
d'un confit pas trop ferme ce fut fort
gay
c'est seulement à l'heure de nuit où
j'ai tiré la porte après le départ du
dernier convive quand je me suis
retrouvé seul dans le séjour en fumée un
petit peu ivres et raisonnablement
fatigué que la précise bouffer d'un
chagrin léger mais remonter aux yeux
agaçante et fugace comme ses envies
d'éternuer qui reste en suspens
à la nostalgie simone la nostalgie
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter mais ils font rien
qu'à me lire dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
c'est non non